you can beat them though
yeah the weber days he was a hunter i
think he was we're live
and we're live we're officially live
podcast episode number 58 we have tom
zenner in the house
we got sosnick in the house and we got
major williams special guest
running for the governor of the state of
california in the house brother good to
have you here
thank you glad the uh petros made the
connection
yes yes great guy petro sent me a uh
text he says pat you gotta
hook up with this guy and then he sent a
group text to us and boom we got on here
and
glad to have you in florida absolutely
glad to be here glad to be here
so uh we got a lot of different topics
to go to i think it's fair first before
we get into the topics that we have we
got
uh first maybe let me preface what
topics we had
buffett and monger made a lot of strong
comments this past weekend about robin
hood about
who's going to be his replacement which
we have the successor's name to be
thinking about and talking about
he he poked at bitcoin they poked a
bunch of different people
their annual meetings i mean i couldn't
even i've never seen him be like this
they just called everybody out
so maybe maybe they've been taking a
class the last 12 months on trolling and
they're trying to see if they can get
better at they're in their 90s
you got to respect them for that they
enrolled in the show so we'll talk about
that we'll talk about the tank uh tanki
takeaways from the meeting that they had
at the berkshire hathaway 2021
shareholder meeting
uh we will get into uh uh a new
uh disneyland obviously reopens after
being closed for about a year but
there's a new scene from disneyland snow
white
ride that's prompting backlash it's very
offensive i think we have to address it
it's catastrophic we will get to it here
in a minute as well
beijing officially taps new york city in
a number of billionaires on latest
forbes list we'll get through that as
well
facebook says decision on whether trump
ban will be overturned coming
wednesday which is tomorrow we're going
to find out what they do about this it's
going to be
a ver i'm actually curious to know what
position they take
on that and we got a bunch of other
topics that we can get into
verizon just sold aol and yahoo for yeah
that's actually
interesting aol who was a juggernaut and
yahoo that was a juggernaut yeah
they sold both for five billion and the
name aol is gone now they're just naming
it
yahoo so aol's
what are you going to do with the aol
chat or rooms you used to go to or you
you were like
i might just change it to aoc email
that's the new up-and-coming is that
really what it's going to be
okay so so prior to getting to all this
stuff let's talk to our friend here
major williams major uh when did you
make the decision to run for the
governor of the state of california
well i started uh well first i just want
to say thank you for having me on the
show i
truly appreciate it big fan i was saying
earlier that you've inspired so many
people
and educated so many people you know
during the you know the course of what
you've
built and what you're doing um i didn't
want to run for governor of california
this wasn't much
on my trajectory i'm not a kid that grew
up with politicians on my wall with
posters
but after i ran for mayor pasadena i
wanted to stay politically active
and i created this this uh this group
this committee called
the new california governor committee
and the pretense was
to stay politically active and support
the next republican governor of
california candidate
so during this process we're uh we're
vetting different individuals that are
non-career politicians
and during the process of me giving my
whole spill
people would just say major you should
just run i can't say it how you said
but also they took the pretense of what
i did locally in pasadena someone that
they said that couldn't
win in pasadena which i didn't win but
the context is
they had to bet that i would only get
100 votes so being in sports and
competitive i said i'm getting 200 votes
right
um but i ended up stealing the voters
block goes got close to 5 000 votes and
so
being able to message mayor of pasadena
mayor pasadena so having that impact
locally
you know a lot of people don't
understand that politics is like any
other industry they they scout out
talent
so people just kept saying you should
run for something oh you should do it
who's calling you who's calling scouting
so these are names are they figureheads
are they people that
you know people would know in the
political world well there were some of
those but it was more so people just
acknowledge
what we've done locally got it um and
ended in different
conventions that we would go to um and
then from there i just you know made
that decision and
you know the story that i always share
with people you know i'm a very
spiritual guy and my grandfather passed
away a few years ago by the name of lj
ding
and the old guy continues to talk to me
especially when i have difficult moments
that i'm dealing with and he came to me
to dream one night at 4 30 morning he
said two words he said step
up and i woke up i prayed with my wife
real briefly told her what happened when
i saw
once i opened up my eyes i literally had
a vision of myself being sworn in as the
41st governor of california and this was
a year ago let's make it happen that's
big yeah that's big so let's find out
what
uh kai if you can pull up major williams
website so what's the story behind
major williams we were asking you with
your name what's the story behind me
sick name yeah i love it you kidding me
so first of all
um i'm not in the military it's not
because of any military background
it really it simplicity came from a
coach one day kind of
using me as an example in a huddle
amongst other players
and they said you know when this guy
gets in the game he's a major
impact so as young kids you know being
immature every time i come to the locker
room oh watch out here comes major
impact
here comes major impact and i thought it
was like something kind of cool so
when i got into music which we were
talking about we were talking about more
i need a you know a rapper name a music
artist name or a writer name and i just
chose major major impact was the actual
name
i made it official three and a half
years ago when i ran for mayor of
pasadena
simply because no one knew me as
courtney lepaul
williams which is what my mother named
me which you know gave me a lot of
fights early on
[Laughter]
and um and that it's really simplistic
it was no long drawn out story when it
comes to that courtney
by the way wasn't it like a stacy
augment stacey augment right
man yeah plastic man he played uh you
know unlv
under the coach right and then he also
johnson larry johnson he went to the
hawks i believe
the guy was left-handed just blanket the
guy who makes you bring up stacy
the name courtney stacy i think some of
the names kind of go both ways
yeah but i got to tell you discovered i
got to tell you i like
major williams that's a killer name
that's kind of like chris paul one day
out of the nba he says changes his name
to general paul
you know it's kind of like that because
they call the general general paul
so you're not advocating he goes back to
courtney no we're good with man i think
i think i think look if my mom she
wanted to know me sasha i
there's no way i'm going to be a sasha
bit david so i can i can respect that
but you do respect sasha baron cohen
he's phenomenal he's so talented it's
ridiculous how he gets into those places
so
so let's go to the website on what
you're running for kai if you can find
that but meanwhile why don't you kind of
tell us some of the issues you're
running for
so running on you know i mean the whole
pretense of why i exist is because i've
been in public
political climate for the last four and
a half years behind the scenes to be
able to see the type of roles of
candidates and also um you know
leadership and i just believe simplistic
simplicity uh the bigger the government
the smaller the people
and so i just ran under the pretense of
what i represent i represent freedom i
represent
liberty uh represent lower taxes and
also
having leadership in place that wants to
empower people when is the last time
you've been inspired by someone in a
political position
and motivating people and just really
caring about education in the sense that
i'm going to be supportive of trade
school
and also support of our small businesses
but in our state
and um and also just making sure that
you have someone as a champion
that's against mandatory uh type of
leadership especially when it comes to
vaccines and bills like sb 276
and 277 and so i wanted to present
myself as an alternative and even
to take it a step further i wanted to be
that
barrier breaker right the person that's
not traditionally
so-called traditionally qualified for
these particular roles i don't come from
10 different you know master degrees or
i'm not a millionaire billionaire type
of individual so what i'm doing is
essentially planting a seed in the next
generation of what politicians or
political service
individuals can be moving forward and if
that's what i inspire
um that's something i will hold dear to
as well you know it's interesting just
a california perspective here you know
they're really i mean that was the time
to do it i mean they needed 1.5 million
signatures
they got 2 million at least 2 million
that's what they're recommending that's
during the lockdown
right right you know i'm just curious
was there a seminal moment for you
because for a lot of people that turned
on newsom
in california it was the french laundry
dinner right that's when it just
solidified everything that he's got to
go he does
not get it right he's dangerous and then
his lack of opening schools was the
other thing big time
he is in major trouble i think major but
was there a moment for you that where
you said i got to get in this i got to
go after this guy and get him out
well i think i was personally affected
you know my wife has a small business
that i help her run as well too and her
business has never
it hasn't opened back up it's been
closed since march of last year and so i
was personally affected but also being
in the political climate i've been
behind the scenes to have those
conversations with family members
and one of the most touching moments
well not really touching moment but
one moment that resonated was a parent
sharing with me and her son that
committed suicide
and this kid got hurt his junior year he
worked his butt off to get prepared for
his senior year
so he didn't get a chance to do that
he's on instagram watching his other
kids
that played his junior year still get
scholarships even though they haven't
played all year
and they took a toll on them and she
shared this story and i literally had
chills
and i had tears in my eyes i heard about
that story and i had tears in my eyes
when she was sharing this very intimate
personal story and so
i do not like bullies i've never liked
bullies even in high school i was five
seven skinny soaking wet i will always
protect people around me and i feel like
governor gavin newsom and his whole
leadership style is bullying to the
point where you're punishing business
owners
for having the audacity to want to take
care of their families and put food on
their tables
and punish our kids uh you know during
this whole extended
uh over politicized lockdown and so at
some point who's going to be that
champion it always takes a certain
moment
a theme or storyline to kind of change
the narrative and if i can be a part of
that
that's what my intention is and so that
was one of the things that kind of
triggered me to really
have this um this motivation to move
forward on it
that's big by the way ky if you go onto
the home page go to the home page so
everybody can see this and do me a favor
and flip the screen go to the screen
make it smaller so the folks can't see
go all the way to the bottom you'll see
in the middle says
four against uh did you change okay keep
going go a little lower when i'm on the
side i go to the bottom it tells me what
he's for what he's against
so i am on major for governor.com is
that what you're on okay right
uh where does it say he's four and he
should be at the top should be all the
way
up okay right there okay pro god family
freedom life leos firefighters first
responders armed forces
forest management legal immigration
second choice community collaboration
second amendment
innovation entrepreneurship sounds like
texas or florida
anti-mandatory vaccination uh human
trafficking voter fraud high taxes over
regulation hate group socialism
communism online censorship defunding
police
sounds like uh washington new york and
california
so the question for you you lived in
texas for quite some time before
i'm originally from dallas texas so
there's a couple different kinds of
friends that i have in california
i lived in california 24 years right in
uh
uh february of 2015
we left and we moved 2016 we moved to
texas dallas and i put my headquarters
in addison and we were there for five
years our headquarters the insurance
company i run is still
headquartered in dallas i moved the
media company over here
we have now roughly 30 employees we're
here in boca raton right so
i'm one of the guys that left iran right
went to germany at a refugee camp as
much as i love iran it was tough to kind
of stay there with the family they made
a decision to leave
we go to germany then we come to la then
i joined the army i go to
you know fort campbell all these other
places then i move my business to texas
easy airport three hours i'm going all
over the place i can go to new york in
three hours it's easy florida downside
travel six hours yet taxes lifestyle all
of those things so
if texas and california had a baby it
would be florida that's what i always
say right
but in california there's two
communities here's the two communities
and i'm curious to know how you're going
to speak to both of these communities
the one community is
those who are sitting there saying
i don't know if this thing's going to
change any time soon okay if you go back
and look at the last republican was uh
arnold schwarzenegger when he was not
really a republican right he was more of
a
center left somewhat right but
some issues left some issues right no
one would consider him right
as a real republican maybe the last
republican may have been an armenian by
the way duke medjan right maybe there
was somebody after him that was also
republican
after duke medjen but what do you say to
the folks who are in california
who have no desire to leave their
families are there they grew up their
kid you know they grew up there friends
relationship restaurants small
businesses churches they go to
they really don't want to leave the
place
but right if they get forced they're
willing to make the move just like a lot
of these other guys made where intel
left to texas
you know you got musk left you got the
rogan left you got a bunch of these
phillips miracles oracle
mickelson left years ago they wrote an
article about him and then tiger talks
about it quite like listen don't talk
about your left california just kind of
keep it down
tell me what about the love letter you
wrote yeah i wrote a love letter to
california but the question i got for
you
is both to both the folks who are
thinking about
leaving and those who the idea is
becoming more serious well maybe it's
not in the next three six twelve months
maybe it's a two three four five year
move
what would you tell them for them to
reconsider wanting to leave the state of
california
well i would tell them you know there's
still a lot of opportunity california
is the uh it's the epitome of states
like it's the brand of brand of all
states regardless of whatever we're
going through right now there's an
opportunity for it to quickly turn
around with the right culture and
leadership
in place and so if you understand what
we are representative
we're representative of in regards to
what we're offering with our brand the
leadership
that in itself should give you some
excitement but what i found
traveling across the state of california
for the last year is that
everyone is united in frustration and i
always say that everyone is united in
frustration and as you
hit on earlier today there's so much
opportunity people are looking for the
opportunity so if you have someone that
comes in
with better solutions and better ideals
there is a dynamic
that tells people that we can change it
and they're not
they're in a place right now where no
one is speaking to them to kind of
change it no one is actually trying to
work to solve their
problems and what makes me uniquely
different is that
i let them you know join the
conversation on how we change things
here in
in the state of california and a lot of
people haven't done that it's normally
the politicians saying
i have the magic wand i have it all
figured out i have all the answers
trust in me believe in me whereas i say
i believe in us
so far we've been in the stands of
frustration together now we have to take
ourselves out of the stands of
frustration get on the battlefield in
our political arena or our state
put on jerseys and fight for it
collectively together as players
versus being spectators and that message
in itself gets people fired up and it
changes the mindset of
what you really think about this
particular state because it can change
significantly easily if california was a
business friendly state
the dynamics drastically changed because
it's a domino effect if you change the
economics
and the budget criteria it affects
everything else including homelessness
and
i actually took your advice in regards
to my platform i don't know if you saw
me uh posting about it
in regards to eliminating the state tax
right and
bringing in and implementing a tourist
tax that was something i directly
someone sent me the link i was like
i like that you know and so i i adopted
that and so that's flexible leadership
that's actually trying to
it shows you're listening it shows your
absolutely what the people are saying
absolutely and i think that's what's
resonated and i think that conversation
in itself
gives them a little pause you know why i
like his
angle is because it's the complete
opposite here's a guy who
left texas to california right you know
you look at the stats
on the the state of texas is california
last year the entire population
increased by twenty thousand net
only twenty thousand that's a small
number when you have 40 million people
when you got 41 million people making
babies you shouldn't increase by 20
000. i think 132 000 people left last
year
state of california to another place
that's 32 600.
132 000 that's the third highest ever
that's the third highest effort in a
year to leave it's not the highest but
it's the third highest ever
i think your approach because think
about it this way
california florida texas new york when
covet hit
it was those four players it's almost
like eastern conference
western conference right you got eastern
conference you got you know
the the you got the [ __ ] got the mic
you got the next miami hitting you got
the moment
i don't think they're going to make it
out of these this year this year's got
brooklyn you got philly you got
milwaukee i see where you're going with
this i'm saying we got
new york with the head coach being cuomo
okay you got california with the head
coach being
new son you got texas head coach being
abbott and you got florida the head
coach being the santas right
he's the big winners right now can we
say when it first started it was
it was a cuomo show it was all a promo
show cuomo was on tv
big time right here you were on team
cuomo
i loved seeing him and his brother
banter that was for me it's i
i like a good banter i just watched
those guys go out and i'm like man i
i'd love to just see how this family is
doing thanksgiving i appreciate
that kind of banter right but next thing
you know
you know this guy went from cuomo could
be the next president he can go up
against trump and people are like whoa
this guy could be the next candidate as
you know what do you call a democratic
president and new some
superstars look what they're doing
responsible decisions they're making
and and abbott and the santas look like
they're reckless
yeah reckless governor so for the first
six months we were saying
california is going to win the
championship new york's going to win the
championship
then when it came to playoff time they
screwed up yeah so in other words
what we talked about earlier the phoenix
suns are a season
team some teams are playoff teams maybe
california
and and you know florida and texas are
uh what do you call it playoff teams but
we got a candidate like this that's
presenting texas ideas
yeah in a state like california imagine
that
you know pat and here's the other thing
too and major you know you got newsome
right now who i think is just governing
to save his ass
i mean basically everything he does
right now is the opposite of what he was
doing before
to appease people to give them a little
bit of hope i mean la's open there were
no deaths in la the last two days cases
are so low
it's unbelievable but someone has a huge
opportunity in california right
people are ticked off it's all we talk
about like dinner parties you get
together on the weekend you're talking
to friends parents groups and
what i'm hearing again it's both
democrats and republicans totally
totally yeah so and it wasn't a
republican recall
let's make sure that we prefer yeah 19
are democrats we looked at the numbers
yeah 19
of the recalls that's what it's being at
yeah we're trying to spin this as this
is you know a bunch of trumpers you know
q and on and it's the people that
stormed the capital
which is not true right everybody's
upset i guess my question is
what's your strategy where's the
opportunity for you because i think if
you
zeroed in on moms on parents you know
people
are really ticked off they opened our
schools for two hours
so if you've got a kid in middle school
and then one in high school like we do
you're going back and forth to school
twice a day right it makes no sense
my daughter's on the track team at
miracosta in manhattan beach freshman
she doesn't know she's gonna have a meet
on friday because the county hasn't
okayed it yet they're waiting on a
county to okay here's the last one
dash plays flag football you know he
gets after it you know big baller you
know playing a game of flag football for
an hour
at the end of the game they won't let
them shake hands you have to wave at
them from across the field even though
you know you've already just played yeah
so i think mom's
parents i think if you like zeroed in
logic and said you're for them i mean
plus the other thing there's going to be
over 100 names potentially on this
ballot
so they're going to get buried if you
you want to be that name that people are
getting there's going to be over 100
names on this ballot there can be
it always is for the most part on a
recall there's no limit
so when arne won it there were over 100
names on the ballot
because you have to answer two questions
do you want new some out and who do you
want in right yeah so then you just got
to have that name that people will find
why don't you do us a favor and explain
what the hell this recall
even is and before you do that let me
just kind of tee up
where my mind is at because he lived in
california for 20 something years
you live in california currently you've
been there 20 years
i'm a florida boy i'm a miami boy i
didn't really realize
how divisive politics was until i really
started kind of mixing it up with i'm
from florida right it's as purple as the
state
as it gets i know we've had some issues
especially in 2000
but i guess simply put what the hell is
going on in california
i went with pat and he took me just to
show the homeless situation that's going
on there like come on you got to see
what's going on there
tom sends a video of his car getting
blown up or is your buddy's car getting
blown up
with the homeless situation we talked
about in san francisco there's like poop
maps going on whatever that story is
right there
so from florida i guess here's my
question you would always hear it's like
the top 10 gdp in the world the state of
california it's hollywood it's silicon
largest economy fifth largest economy
you could ski and
surf in the same day you know california
like all you hear all these things and
now the the brand is
completely tarnished from what you would
i mean depending on what you see
right the homeless situation the the
people moving out of the
uh out of the state san francisco pat
went down the the list of names that are
getting the hell out of there
what's happened i mean what and and part
b to that is
why is california politics so divisive
like we don't have that divisiveness
here in florida so i'm like hold on you
give him like 17 questions
why are you testing them out okay what
the hell happened to california
why is it so divisive and tell us about
the recall the guy just said he doesn't
have 10 mbas
he's making a major impact don't
overwhelm them
why is it so divisive and explain the
request well first of all
so first of all it tells you how jacked
up california is the fact that pat has
to take someone to the state to see how
jacked up it is as if it's a museum
exhibit right
homelessness is rising through the roof
over the last two years it is uh
it is claimed i think 16 to 18 percent
the recall has actually happened because
it it's there's been frustration even
before the lockdowns and that's what a
lot of people are not framing in full
context
there have been a lot of decisions
questionable decisions based upon gavin
newsom's leadership
some of the policies and legislation
that he support that he has supported
and that he has implemented uh and the
process
is basically you know you know getting
the votes over the particular threshold
which they have done that even during
the lockdown and being suppressed and no
press
time and time again and as i said
earlier people just united in
frustration
until you change the culture of
leadership in any
whether it's a company whether it's
anything you're not going to be able
to change the culture of the outcome
doing the exact same thing over and over
again expecting different results is
called what it's called insanity we all
know that
so in order to change that we have to
have a different mindset and that's kind
of like what we're offering up
once more i come into every situation
with full transparency right and the
beautiful thing about what i represent
and how we're going to galvanize people
and also win because people are more
receptive to the normal
uh straightforward conversation as i
said earlier i don't have a magic wand
i don't have every single answer but if
you look on my website there is a
restored california plan the restored
california plan
is a live open document task force
meaning that you can leave a video
message and add your insight your input
versus just complaining
now you have an opportunity to be a part
of us actually coming to the table to
start talking about solutions and i
think once that's implemented with a
different brand of leadership we're
going to see a change at a time when it
comes to collaboration
let me ask you a question let me ask a
question because a current
playbook of being a governor or
president has changed it's changed
obviously arnold did it being a
celebrity and he won i think 5.3 million
to 3.7 3.9 million when he went up
against an opponent
his opponent his opponent and oh
whatever the year was when he won oh
three
uh oh three yeah three so so the
playbook is the rock
will you run for office you know what i
would cuz i don't know if god is looking
down saying he sees it you know big that
you can tell that was kind of like he
was prepared to give that answer
but uh you know if it came down to it i
would love to be a president so what's
rock saying he's hinting that he's gonna
run because he's following
arnold and trump's playbook like look at
trump becomes a president through
twitter obama he realizes what's going
on with social media gives that 2004
speech
right everybody's talking about around
the world he becomes a rock star boom he
becomes a president right
your your presence online is not strong
yet you don't have a big enough presence
so how do you plan on
making up for that because messaging
when somebody if i close my eyes and i
just listen to what you're saying i'm
like
amazing phenomenal fantastic
great i agree i like it i love it
your biggest enemy will be raising money
who was the other one that's running for
governor in the state of california cox
is it
that had 19 million dollars or something
uh the last time he ran yeah the last
time i mean he already put up a million
dollar
million dollars yeah so much so you're
going to have a money issue
you're going to have a social media not
not seeing you that's what i'm trying to
say what you're going to say money
issues social media issue
a big name endorsing you issue to bring
you out as a star because you know
a lot of times someone needs to come out
and say this guy's a star let's get
behind him right whether
you can't have trump do that to you
because if you that you're not going to
win the state of california you
so it's not trump's in your big star it
cannot be romney we saw what happened to
romney yesterday
he's booed off the stage if you have tim
scott you know if you have a
you know thomas soul you know is a he
can't he's not even going out nowadays
who what is going to be your strategy to
go through those three
you know hurdles you're going to be
facing by in in order to become a
governor
so i don't necessarily look at it as a
hurdle i look as an amazing opportunity
because you have to look
at the full context know my social media
isn't as huge as some of the people that
you may be speaking of but the thing
about it look at how fast it's risen
this my social media has only been in
existence for 317 days
and we're really at you know a million
followers but we're being shadow banned
and suppressed
but also believe that the representation
of the message and what i represent
when i go out and speak with the farmers
when i go out and speak in the projects
when i go out and speak with the soccer
moms
resonates differently than anyone else
when it comes to messaging and i think
that's what a lot of people are missing
and i tell people i feel like our
campaign is a hit record
but it just isn't fully funded yet you
got to understand
i am the first candidate to register to
run for governor
with the apprentice pretense of it being
in 2022.
so i've been in this game long enough uh
to understand
pace and also when to peak so when
people are professing that i'm not going
to raise enough money this is what i do
my background is in marketing my thing
my superpower was making their
presentation
whether it was your product your service
or whatever to get the yes to check off
when church is a
man this is what i do right and so i
understand the dynamics of patience
and i like being in the position of
so-called underdog or
he's not no it's patience and i just
have to peak at the right time even if
it's a hundred candidates it doesn't
matter
if i peak at the right moment because i
do have those like abilities if
you close your eyes and i stand for a
lot of things that you appreciate
if i peak at the right moment at the
right time i have a lot of dynamics that
can win votes
from all sides which is why we have so
many volunteers that are democrats
independents libertarians etc because we
have such a broad
understanding of how to connect with
people that's the first thing i noticed
on your website was 2022. so regardless
what happens this fall you win it next
fall too
okay i think a long term i think long
term
you know you're uh uh you're a star
long term i think it's gonna eventually
happen my my challenge is
guys want you today guys want a person
that you stand for these things today
not eight years from now or
yeah you know god knows california needs
somebody with those belief systems today
by the way
if you're if you're following the
podcast and you're enjoying what we're
talking about smash that thumbs up
button
uh if you're glad that we have a major
williams on and hit the subscribe button
as well while you're on there by the way
i put
major williams instagram profile in the
chat box if you haven't followed him
go give him a follow i just put the link
right there literally click on it go
give them a follow maybe even
dm dm him a message but going back to
that going back to
you know you running for uh you know
governor so let's just say we have 100
candidates
right has anybody yet start trashing you
and you know spreading rumors has that
happened yet has it happened where
they're writing negative articles
against you
have you already experienced a little
bit of that because that's actually a
very good thing if you have yeah so even
when i ran for mayor pasadena god
created
a a instagram page specifically for me
it's called protect pasadena and it it's
all stuff
of me trashing me so of course um
two weeks ago i spoke at the san diego
gop
uh the four out of all the candidates
that only invited four candidates
it was me it was doug aussie it was
kevin faulconer it was john cox
so that that that just rubbed a lot of
people the wrong way the fact that they
still invited me
and why did it rub people the wrong way
that you got invited because the
audacity of some of these people feel
like they're they're more credible or
they've been in this a long time right
and the fact that they invited major
williams and you know all these people
like this guy like why do they like him
so after that i spoke first obliterated
everyone
we did a random raffle and i spoke my
truth is it's live on social media and
i close by saying california isn't
missing the richest or smartest
leader uh california is missing a leader
and also a candidate with relatability
boom mic drop and after that the date
the next day attacks galore sure so
there's a hundred people running for
this runoff would you just kind of back
up
in 2003 though okay gotcha right now
it's like 19.
okay and caitlyn jenner is one of them
yeah so
she are we going with she did she's not
getting invited uh
to the stage she's she's got name
presents yeah hannah now [ __ ] okay
gotcha there was no announcement
is that someone who you're looking at as
a legitimate competitor
no i'm not i'm not looking at anyone as
a competitor
i say personally i would vote for an
electrician before i vote for any of the
people that are there now because at
least an electrician there's in
completion
all these individuals by the way can you
say that one more time folks if you were
doing anything
else i heard you say that at one of your
rallies you were up there on stage
talking about it please listen to what
he just said can you repeat that
one more time so the person that i would
vote for or i would wish
was running was someone that has like
the pedigree of an electrician
because at least an electrician they
deal in completion and what i mean by
that's your habits and your mindset
when you go into an office or house or
whatever
they have to complete that job to get
the yes or their approval right so
that's the process politicians don't
deal in completion
they're dealing pushing paper and
pushing and pushing the narrative on
someone else
with that how did you that even well i'm
an entrepreneur a small business owner
so me and my wife have to figure out
creatively how to keep the lights on
every single month
so we're always ambitiously working
towards completion we have to have
completion to take care of our three
boys
politicians these guys are career
scholars or academia
right and they're just they don't know
they don't have they don't have any
imagination on how to solve the
so-called complex
issues and problems that that they
continue to talk about i have a i have a
marketing strategy for you that i'm i'm
going to
share with you here publicly but a guy
here is asking a question ryu karito
just gave 10 bucks to saying what's your
plan to lower taxes i make
dollars and fifty cents an hour and i
seem barely
to scrape by when i get overtime or make
extra in two week pay
i've been taxed as much as seven hundred
dollars for that how do you plan on
lowering taxes in the state of
california
one of the ways so we can't even address
taxes until
you have leadership in place that wants
that understands how to create new
revenue
new revenue actually allows you to go to
the table to talk about reducing taxes
and so
for me it's about making california
business friendly reducing regulations
and also giving incentives to bring
businesses back
also to support the small business as
well once you do that
then you can actually sit at the table
with the legislators to talk about
reducing taxes
the reason why i you know use that first
is because
the first thing legislators are going to
tell you is that we can't reduce taxes
because it's for this
or because it's for this but if you have
leadership that knows how to create a
dollar
that knows how to create new revenue
that kind of like cancels that out right
and so
it has to be layers it is chess it's not
checkers you have to have pace and
strategy when it comes to that yeah
that is intense you're going to make a
lot of media people uncomfortable
because they're not going to know what
to do with you i mean the la times the
san francisco chronicle
yeah you know the big media that's
what's great about it yeah well they
know what to do with me they're going to
trash me
yeah but you know what that just shows
how hypocritical they are because
they're all for
inclusion and everything else until it's
a republican or something what did they
call tim scott they called him uncle tom
yeah yeah or something like that so
it's interesting why would you say they
wouldn't know what to do with them
because he makes a lot of sense number
one and he's african-american you know
and and it should be you know somebody
that they should be getting behind and
supporting
especially with all the common sense
ideas they're saying just because he's a
republican they would not have
well pretty much yeah republican
african-american those two
you know go together by the way what do
you think about when you think about
martin luther king
for me he was inspirational i love the
fact that he was complex i love the fact
that he wasn't perfect but i also know
that his words resonated with
many people during that time and period
and it resonates even to this day for a
lot of people
now that's a poster that i had on my
wall growing up as well too
but i also um you know show resentment
for uh history
because you know those are the only
brands that i knew growing up when now
as a mature adult
i find that there are so many other
individuals that are out there as well
such as well i mean even in my high
school
in elementary we never even heard of
like frederick douglass and that's crazy
because that's like
you know even now like we know of that
right and so
um his writing he wrote what's the one
book he wrote the uh
uh he he's the complete
opposite of victimhood mentality that's
what he writes about whatever is the
opposite of victim of men he says
responsibility you can make a change you
can make something happen for yourself
accountability accountability is a big
thing yeah
you were telling me about that when we
spoke in my studio over there about how
you had to look in the mirror and he
said i wasn't reading
yeah and you had to take accountability
and say all right i need to step my game
up tell us about that
well i hit a point in my life where i
was 12 years ago i was in a club in
hollywood
and everybody was having fun and the
lights were strobing and people popping
and literally you know it was one of
those moments where um
everything was moving in slow motion
like why is everything moving in slow
motion right everything is moving slow
motion so i started reflecting and i
remember something i said i just paid 20
to park and i'm in the club right now
and i have no money to even buy a drink
and you know my wife is at home and like
what am i my grown
you know 30 some year old guy while i'm
in the club right now what is my life
worth
like what what is my legacy going to be
which is why i say today the two
one of the the two top things that are
most important to me right now is
what are my three sons and my wife are
going to say about me when it's all said
and done
at my eulogy and the other component is
what what is the legacy and the value
that i added you know while i was here
and so from that particular day at that
that night i went home and cried on my
my wife's shoulder and said i've been a
failure my wife slapped me and said no
you're not get it together wow
we moved out of hollywood area we moved
to pasadena california i spent two years
in the pasadena public
library re-educating reprogramming
myself by myself
came out created a social media company
had 200 small businesses i was doing the
social media for paying me a thousand
dollars a month for six month
agreements and everything else is the
dynamics changed from there love that
let's go back on what we were talking
about so so frederick douglass big
inspiration who else what other names
so uh i got really into uh les brown
okay
les brown is legendary no question in
regards to
his mindset the way he thinks but more
importantly and this is why resonate is
through the story
right it's not necessarily just like the
bullet points of his share it's actually
the story that walks you through his
life
that makes that personal connection with
you you know the fact that my ability to
walk in the projects and speak with the
kid with his pants sagging with braids
and also speak to the soccer moms but
also speak with the millionaire and
billionaires because why i've existed in
all those spaces successfully but i'll
have real experiences
in those spaces so people like that are
very inspiring
about thomas soul i love thomas i love
him i've been into him for the last four
and a half years
and uh it's just a different it's just
refreshing right it's one of a kind
it's refreshing to see someone think at
a higher plane like that and just kind
of like pushes you to be your better
self
so so martin luther king he was a
registered republican right
who would have mlk been today so bring
him to today
who would he have been so imagine all
the protesting all the writing that's
going on the looting the business all
the stuff that happened in 2020
who who would he have been out there
campaigning today that's a good question
um
i believe would he have been supportive
of the blm movement
no he wouldn't have been supportive i
don't think so he would have been
supportive of black lives matter yeah
as a name as a as a you know but not
what
not the organization in their mission
statement he wouldn't be for that are
you
i'm i'm for black community i'm for our
lives matter you know so
break down the difference as being a
black man who's you said seen all
sides of the track and you can speak to
anyone what is blm what is the black
community give us
as a father you know everything package
it all up well the black community is
very simplistic it's just the black
culture it's the black community when
you
you know the black uh the blm is kind of
it's an organization so it's a separate
entity that you can actually join to be
a part of and that you bought into
based upon their ideology the process
and things that they produce or don't
produce
uh of course we find that there's a lot
of things that they don't produce
in regards to the money that they've
raised because they haven't put back
into the black community and the culture
but for me i can stand beside someone or
organization or group that has that
mindset or the structure with their uh
with their mission statement
and i think it's uh i think it's a very
divisive tool
when you see because i know you played
some ball i used to play a little ball
so did uh mr zeno over here we got the
middle eastern dennis rodman and dvd
over here
great great elbows watch out for those
elbows but when you see
um is it greg yes okay he you know he
he was in the in the point that i'm
getting as in the nba
they took a very clear-cut line stance
on blm
social justice their ratings kind of
tanked yeah i mean my heat were in the
final so i was good with that all but
lakers the one that won the finals l.a
so
sum that all up how i mean are you a
lebron guy are you not a lebron guy are
you part of the social justice how do
you
how do you deal with all that there's
different perspectives on all that
well my perspective is i'm going to
exist in my own particular free will in
my own space i believe
uh i i love lebron's skill set i love
his
personal agenda on how he's orchestrated
his family and also his friends that
he's put around him he has a great
blueprint for other people to follow
i'm just not aligned with his political
beliefs and some of the things that he's
done
and how he has used his platform i've
actually reached out to him via
instagram because i would love to have
a different conversation with them when
you're at that height in that particular
level you have certain people around you
and i was a democrat by default right
and it took for someone to kind of like
enlighten me on what
happened to you four and a half years
ago who was that that sat down with a
gentleman by the name of cole harris
he ran for lieutenant governor of
california that was my entry into
politics
what was the selling what was the what
did he say to you that you flipped
so we're in his backyard at a birthday
party at his house
and he leaned over to me and said i'm
going to be running for lieutenant
governor the first thing i said what is
that i didn't even know what lieutenant
that's four and a half years ago yeah
four and a half years ago
pre-trump yes okay well right around the
same time so is it fair to say you were
an obama guy at least until that point
oh absolutely okay
but from the just by default was it
because i can remember any kind of great
policies because they don't exist
right um and then we sort of
then we started going like that line
right there boom boom then we started
going down the rabbit hole
of policy and what i was able to
identify as a free thinker as
it was a policies that was beneficial
and also detrimental but then i was able
to apply that to how i grew up
so my mother used to tell me that the
government loved us but what she really
meant was democrat loved us
the democrats loved us simply because of
the welfare check she was getting right
so as a kid and your mother is telling
you this they're protecting us so i feel
that they're they're for us but there is
a ceiling right
people you know you don't understand
that at that particular point
conservatism for me
and and my cole harris i'm speaking
about
it was explained simplistically
simplistically like republicans and
conservatives we rather show you how i
made that hundred dollars
versus give you that 100 because that
empowers you
you know i love what you said about
lebron because i think that would be a
great strategy for you because
whether you like lebron's politics or
not and he's very polarizing and he's
really really gone really far lately but
he's brilliant he's smart i mean you
can't argue with that and i don't think
he'd have a lot of arguments against you
and i think if you could have a
reasonable conversation that's why you
started this
my thing is if black lives do matter
lebron yeah you should at least talk to
me i'm making history
but you have so much credibility to have
that conversation with him and hopefully
he'd be
allow himself to listen yeah because you
would not have a bigger megaphone and if
you don't go
go to maverick carter you know he's an
entrepreneur just like you yeah go
go to those guys and stay at them
because that would be a great have you
heard back from their camp at all
not yet but i do need to reach out to
the additional individuals like maverick
and also rich paul as well too
because like i said i love their story i
like the fact that he
empowered them and made them get
educated to come on board to help him
run his organization and whatnot and if
they're actually interested in
making an impact and making a change
they should sit down and have a
conversation with you
right because what we've seen is if you
don't speak you like
you know to use a uh international
relations you don't make peace with your
friends you make peace with your enemies
and i'm not saying that you guys are
enemies
but finding some common ground
especially you running
as uh for governor it would be
it would be very advantageous for you
guys tell lebron you need to get into
the barber shop i mean really that show
was created
that was created for debate i mean if he
had guts he'd invite you right into that
show and i would go i would actually
maverick seems like the kind of guy that
would bring you
likelihood of that happening likelihood
of that i'm gonna hold out hope i'm
gonna say 30 percent
likelihood of that happening give me a
percentage likelihood of lebron actually
putting him at the ball because lebron
likes to be challenged so let's see if
he's going to respond to
bronze likely likely likelihood of this
happening and him reaching out because
by the way there was another lapd
officer that reached out to lebron as
well to have a private one-on-one
yeah big guy i don't know what is i
don't know if you saw that or not this
was last week
likelihood of lebron i'm an optimist i i
really like major's
message i i think he could relate to
lebron 51
he should because we come from very
similar backgrounds right uh
single parent household grew up in
poverty you know you're both
entrepreneurs
both entrepreneurs both were willing to
uh sacrifice ourselves and
and work hard and and just really want
to do well he created the school that
was a great thing i have my non-profit
major kicks for kids we give away over a
thousand pair of shoes
every single year 2 000 haircuts put on
empowerment
events for the for the next generation
why do you think
that someone like lebron or someone as
outspoken as any of these nba leaders as
it ex
has not come over to your way of
thinking as an example you said i mean
the the faction can you tell me the
first time ever lebron sat with an
opposing argument
like when have you ever seen lebron
still with an opposing argument yeah
when he sat with uh the guy about uh
coming down to south beach i'm taking my
town to south that's not that's not
when is the last time he sat with
somebody dance that opposes
what was it the fact that i'm taking my
talents to south beach that's not
opposing
it's not bad there's backlash because of
a decision but what i'm asking you is
when is the last time conversationally
that he sat down with somebody that
opposes
on camera on camera probably not a lot
but i assume behind closed doors he'll
have
already meetings with yes people that
say yes i agree with you i don't know i
don't know if that's
better to say
yeah here's what i i hope i'm wrong
lebron sees this i'm hoping i'm wrong
i'm hoping i'm wrong and he says screw
you pat
me maverick and rich will sit with him i
hope he says you have no clue what the
hell you're talking about what i do
behind closed doors phenomenal i'll go
after some i was wrong great
but i'm telling you right now the
chances of that happening is less than
five percent yeah
on the media but behind closed doors
less than five percent of even him even
meeting with major williams behind
closed doors becky right now major
williams you win there do it
he's in there i'm a teenager baby you're
gonna put a thousand
no no this is not about him i know
back to my original question why is
lebron a democrat why is he
so outspoken anti-trump are you on team
trump that's a part b
question and why are a lot of the nba
guys democrats explain that why aren't
80-90
of african-americans democrats well the
thing about it is as i said earlier in
my conversation it's really by default
right
if you're cultivated under the mindset
that they are for you at a very early
age you take that into your your teenage
years your early adult years and your
later years if you're not
informed correctly as pat was saying if
you're surrounded by
yes men and and and and people who just
agree you're saying that black people in
general or more the lebron
no the black culture is strongly
indebted to
uh you know the democrat policy and
you're saying that that it's
um what was the word you used indebted
or what was the other word you said that
it's by default by default
okay by default i've got another
strategy for you pat what do you think
of this he needs to get on bill maher's
show
you'd be perfect on bill maher's show
who's your publicist by the way
uh ryan mccormick in new york okay mar
would have you i mean he he takes
you know different opinions and
different voices that would be a great
one
you know who's playbook you know you
know who did a great job in a last
presidential campaign
that went from nobody knowing him the
day before to all of a sudden being a
big name you know who the mayor of notre
dame or andrew
oh yeah yeah well now he's running for
mayor right yeah yeah andrew yeah but by
the way
yeah you've got to see these two
playbooks so today is possible and i
have
if you have an argument to do that so
for you so i think that's the playbook
but
here's here's here's one thing i was
going to say like you know the whole
thing is
having a campaign that sticks right if i
tell you herman cain
you know obviously he's not here with us
anymore you know but herman cain's
campaign was what
999 you know you know if you if god only
wants 10
you can give you know the government
nine percent right nine percent federal
nine percent remember the whole thing he
did with nine i don't know if you
remember that
i remember mccain godfather pizza i
don't remember the night yeah that was
his nine gimmicks
all the time and it's stuck with people
right right
if you go to great campaigns of what
they talked about that stuck you have to
have a campaign that sticks a slogan
that sticks right
to me it would be the song by james
brown
try me you know the song try try me
try me right okay i thought you're going
papa's got a brand new bag
before you leave california my campaign
would be try me before you leave
california try me before you leave
california
before you leave california here's why i
would focus on the people that are
thinking about leaving california
because
those will be the true believers not the
other guys that are not going to move
get to the person that's sitting there i
talked to my buddy basketball player you
know who i'm talking about you met him
we went to ralphie's place
baller steve we're leaving a heartbeat
you know why he can't leave
you got mom dad cousin brother sister
business relatives he's supporting so
many people it's a tough it's a tough
move to leave right
but i will tell you a lot of these guys
are actually thinking about they're
considering the potential of moving
but if somebody says look before you
move try me i'm telling you before you
move california try me
there how many people right now in
california at a 41 let's actually let's
actually quantify this number let's
actually quantify this number
california's got 41 million people what
percentage of 41 is under 18.
let's pick 20 right let's say out of the
41 under 18 is what eight million okay
let's see out of the 41 in california
what percentage is over 65 that's not
going to move anywhere let's say another
15 so that's 35 you got what you got 25
million people left
out of the 25 million people left what
percentage are democrats that will never
leave california
okay let's say 50 percent which is what
20 20 half so we're left with 20 million
out of that i'd say more than 50 let's
say let's say we have
we have 10 million left out of that 10
million that's left in the state of
california
how many of them do you think have had
the conversation
not that they're gonna move have had a
serious conversation at the kitchen
table
saying bait what about nevada what about
texas
what about florida what about you've had
the conversation you just haven't left
many have had the conversation but they
just haven't left
but they're on the tipping point how
many people you think have had the
conversation tipping point
but they just can't make the move but
they've had the conversation
a lot and you don't give me a number 12
million
more maybe i don't know if it's 12
million six what do you think i mean you
might know you would know a million
votes to win that's all you need
i would say a good at least four million
people so
that's four million people they're
saying 10 of californians are
considering leaving yeah is that the
number
by the way those are true believers
believers in what
meaning they don't want to leave yeah
you can
keep them but if you have if you can
if you can fight for me to say dude i
love california i don't want to leave
but i want somebody that's going to be
able to make some changes
before i leave because we're seriously
having a conversation if i market myself
and i targeted to a specific audience
that obvious audience that's a true
believer they will convert just like the
recall
the recall how many recall conversations
do you think happen at a kitchen table
just like this just like the lieutenant
governor had the conversation with him
saying hey four and a half years ago
here you know
republicans teach you how to make 100
bucks democrats say here's 100 bucks
right the difference on how that
principle stuck with them with coal
right right if if the people are having
a conversation right now saying dude
before you leave
try major williams and i i actually
think that's absolutely amazing for
one for like 11 months i worked for
directv back in 2010 right
and one of the taglines on the sales on
the phones and i was really good at it
uh we would say this line um so this is
good for you because
it's very simple but when you say that
in gesture
in that way it always percentage-wise
got people to think and pause
and it felt like i was adding value you
know this is good for you because and i
use that in my
mayoral run as well i would always say
that and this is good for you because
and then i will identify the issue the
problem the cause or the fix
right so the fact that now i'm
positioning myself like try me yeah
and i know psychologically morality the
morale is low
and so for someone to present themselves
as as try me and it's actually me and an
image
of what i represent as to it you know
and let's take it full circle regardless
what we represent like i'm not a career
politician i came out here with
different ambitions and i've tried
different things right
that's what a lot of americans have done
that's what a lot of californians have
done especially in the hollywood area
right we want to be moguls or
multifaceted right
i've been with my wife since the third
day i moved here right she was one of
the main reasons why i
stayed in california and we've been
together 21 years
you know i have a black wife you know
that's a lot and all of us conservatives
don't have that as well and it's not to
put anyone on blast but when you're
talking about leadership
and that's relatable uh broadly that
that factors in as well
i'm a marketing guy so i understand
those dynamics i think you're very
marketable yeah
i think you're very marketing you've got
one quality going for you that's stan
you're likable
i mean people people can't walk away
they might not just they might not agree
but they're not going to dislike you and
that's that's a huge win
because if you multiply that by every
room you get into or every interview you
can do man you can you can turn people
well that's what's happening so the
the the uh the smear campaign that's
happening right now
is that they have nothing but they're
using everything from my past all the
way to now to try to have ammunition to
make people not like me so they're
sharing stuff my tumblr account
they're sharing like stuff from like all
old stuff when i did music and all this
stuff
like how is he gonna be governor if he's
making music and raunchy videos and
stuff like that
but that they don't understand that
they're giving me free promotion yeah
they give me free information
that's my guy i have a question for you
um and i'll limit the two part questions
everybody take a break everyone take a
break now bathroom break the
opening for the major campaign is
ceramics a lot is that
everything full buster begins now
everything with politics is future based
where can you see yourself down the road
right a lot of the things that you'll be
running on
are the the schools aren't locked down
you know the state's on lockdown but
that likely won't be there in the next
few months absolutely
that's a good point won't be
so that's my point is exactly it's like
all right great we're like
clearly gavin newsom screwed up i mean
he i think he had a
wins like a landslide election and 60
percent of the vote
crazy numbers and now he's you know
obviously getting recalled
so future base cause how do you win and
then how does the republican
actually win california i think that's
the biggest question here
it's not about you you clearly have
great ideas it's how does a republican
actually win
so so it really comes down to your skill
set as a candidate uh republicans have
had weak candidates in the past that
hasn't been able to have that
relatability uh that's a different
dynamic for us
uh you win by creating a movement have
great messaging and some of the things
that we're looking at even beyond that
is
just identifying what was the issue even
before the lockdown which is
homelessness and also
us being on business friendly the
trucking industry love me
they're getting pushed out as well and
just solving those particular issues
if you look at the dynamics of what
we're presenting in the restored
california plan it resonates beyond the
lockdown
so we're not just specifically running
the campaign based upon
showing the negativity that came from
the lockdown we also
put a magnifying glass on the things
that were happening before
uh covet actually happened but you gotta
admit major and and i'm a victim of
someone who thinks emotionally rather
than logically that's something that pat
has taught me like chill out bro
chill out bro yeah so you know policies
over
perception you gotta admit man i mean
two-thirds of californians
lean left yeah no no it's true in the
thing
so more liberal so how you win
how you win is what i said last time you
have to
it's kind of like something i took from
les brown my story
having relatability right they cannot
like republicans or
trump which i support it still do down
but it's about the story and i only need
a percentage of people that's why when
he said like a hundred people can
i really don't care because i understand
how to run a successful campaign peak at
the right moment and i know that
what i bring brand wise and messaging
rocks is different from
everybody on the playing field i just
need the right amount of exposure to put
in the work to get out there and get in
front of the people i i got a quote
right you just
i got ryu then i'll ask you a question
then we'll go into our topic so ryu
kirito ryu not ken but ryu asked the
question what is your plan on dealing
with a homelessness problem i live in
corona california i will not step one
foot in la
and the problem is spreading so
we have an amazing idea when it comes to
homelessness we do not look at
homelessness like a business what's
happening right now in california
the governor looks at homelessness like
a business anytime you look at
homelessness like a business there's
more incentive to actually keep it going
and perpetuating the exact same cycle
until we have leadership that knows how
to look at homelessness like a service
with accountability with the
accountability aspects
and accountability aspects of it then it
would change so there are three pillars
that we're going to focus on one is
mental health hospitals being
reimplemented back into society
in california the third one is
accountable drug and rehab facilities
and
the first two that i just mentioned do
not work at all unless you have the
third component which is wraparound
services
i worked in the group home facilities
and non-profits for five years from 2003
to 2007 so i understand what wraparound
services were what is wrap around
service wrap around services then at
that particular time which i co-authored
uh was working with kids that were 17 18
years old to get them acclimated into
adulthood right
so with california you have to it's one
thing to say get mentally
stable right or get off those drugs but
then what
so wrap around services is a customized
tool that we use
to put towards each individual to get
them the services that they actually
need so only then we'll be able to get
people reacclimated back into society
and it's going to take time but if you
don't have a foundation
that's kind of like rooted in that we
will never get to that place where we'll
put it you know there's one there's one
dynamic on the homeless thing to think
about
in la now they tried to clean it up for
the oscars a little bit right yeah they
probably tried to put a fresh coat of
paint on it we got the super bowl coming
up next year
we got the world cup two years after
that and then we've got the olympics
there is no way that they're going to
want to paint this picture of this
homeless problem which is so out of
control now it's unbelievable
everywhere and with that comes crime i
mean the amount of crime
people do not feel safe walking the
streets of beverly hills i've got
friends
business owners won't wear a fancy watch
because they they know that they'll get
it taken from them i just heard about
this woman 65 years old
in beverly hills right on beverly
boulevard coming out of a restaurant
not even armed guy told her i want your
watch take it off she refused she's like
5-2
fought the dude got knocked down broke
her shoulder and her elbow
i mean it's just i heard about it
they've got to start addressing it
because it is so
so out of control no i agree i agree and
it's going to continue that way if we
don't change the dynamics of how we
approach it
uh we're looking at echo park i don't
know if you win by echo parking lot
it was a homeless camp park it was a
homeless camp man that's what it was and
then they just cleaned it up right you
said you used to work out in
venice beach every sunday speech but
echo park echo park is
not the eco park 30 years ago we used to
there was a league we were part of
called the new century city basketball
association we played in echo park all
the time
it was gangsters everywhere it was not
the best place i mean we're talking we i
was part of the league with blood
blood we had [ __ ] we had black diamonds
we had
uh we had everybody that was there
together it was terrible
terrible echo park yeah but we're
talking like 30 years ago i was 14 years
old 2018.
are the bloods and crips things still a
thing in l.a yeah it's still a theme
it's still a thing but it's just not
highlighted in regards to how it used to
be
no no it used to be a thing it's not
what it used to be it's more diplomatic
today than what it was before
40 years ago like colors when that came
out like that's when it was
peaking well did you ever see the meme
that's going around like some guy had a
uh everyone's wearing face masks these
days had a blue handkerchief
a lady had a red handkerchief they're
like it's going down bro
in the supermarket okay but they're okay
no fighting let's go into some issues
let's go into some topics and issues we
got here uh
okay so if you're liking a podcast so
far smash that thumbs up button we're at
2681.
major williams i asked him what are you
going to do if we crack 3 500 he says
well i don't know we're going to have to
have a shot at tequila so
adam would like for us to get to 4 000.
i said let's stay at 34.99 i got a
congress
i'm a team player but we'll see what's
going to happen tom hasn't yeah have you
ever had tequila 10 o'clock in the
morning i don't think i have no i don't
think i've ever had to kill at 10
o'clock in the morning but i've had it
at 7 o'clock
right from the previous game well let's
let our uh
viewers know there's a separate channel
smash the subscribe
everything you talk about yes this is a
setup
and i just said major williams instagram
account again
follow them send them a message dm them
let them know you're watching them here
so let's go into some topics disneyland
reopens page number two after being
closed for more
than a year disneyland reopens after
being closed for more than a year that's
a cnn business story disneyland
uh but many healthy safety protocols
will continue to be enforced the
capacity of the theme park in anaheim
california will be significantly limited
to comply with the
california's health safety requirement
and promote social distancing i think
the number is 25
capacity in addition until further
clarification from the state to
california only california residents
are allowed to visit the disneyland
resort uh theme park so if you're out of
state like we could not go to disneyland
in the state of california
in groups no larger than three per
household three i mean you got what if
you got two kids
health safety measures include
requirements face coverings for all kids
two years old an
older two-year-old temperature
screenings for all guests entering the
park cashless transactions and capacity
limitations at
attractions disneyland's union have
pushed california governor newsom to
reopen the park
earlier this year group of california
state assembly members also proposed a
bill aimed at speeding the reopening
disneyland
and other large theme parks in the state
so
i'll go to you first major williams what
do you think about that
well i you know i think it's been
overextended
in regards to the lockdowns and um
i don't know it's just i mean look at
the dynamics you know
um how they're limiting and creating
this fear and just
this hesitation has happened i think
it's bad culturally i think it's bad
psychologically
and i just don't get like the rationale
the common sense aspect of it
i think um it's once more it's it's not
even
overreach right it's not like overreach
it's just like silliness at the end of
the day so
i can't there's no elaboration on it
it's just it's just
it's just ridiculous if you were
governor what would you do in this
instance
how would you what would your disneyland
policy be well i don't know
i don't i don't know the reach of a
governor when it comes to disneyland
well you got security you can get on
every ride you want
right away there's no lines man when
you're governor
i don't know like i said that's
something you wouldn't delve into is
what you're saying
i mean i i believe that um
you know from a statewide perspective in
policy you know it would be very
transparent in regards to where i stand
when it comes to that but i think it'd
be a little bit harder
uh legally and legislation-wise when it
comes to some company
like disneyland you know one of the good
things is i don't know if you saw this
but when you enter disneyland now the
snow white and the seven dwarfs are
offering you free coveted vaccines i
mean they're in there they're
they're they're they're working hard
wait this is nobody's amazing they're
keeping them busy this is it are you
going to take your kids
to disneyland ah i'm not going to do it
now because it's way too much now wait a
minute
that was a joke yeah that was a joke
you know you're going to see more of
this from newsome unfortunately he's
going to open up disneyland more and
more and declare it a win
here here's the one thing that scared me
the most i don't know if you guys heard
this kamala harris
addressed the united nations and this
kind of has something to do with
disneyland but
did you hear her say we got to get ready
for the next pandemic
i mean that did you hear her say that i
mean i cannot believe that and it also
makes me think about all those
businesses in orange county
those small businesses the hotels all
the vendors
i mean there are so many businesses that
went under and
it is just so ruthless of what happened
there and you wonder
is he against them or was this a
strategy to shut down some small
businesses
you will have people say that that's
been part of his strategy as well
to literally take out some of the small
businesses and make you dependent on it
but i think psychologically it's helpful
that disneyland is open it's the
happiest place on earth right you know
it should be open
so you you live there why you wouldn't
take your family i i just want to okay
right now it's like a resident
it's way too complicated i mean all the
time everything i want to go i'm just
gonna wait online to get tickets i mean
eventually when it opens up again
well you gotta you gotta have a
reservation first of all you can't just
go
you can't you can't you can't
can you imagine you got to make a
reservation i'll do a party or four six
o'clock
friday night yeah pathetic what they're
doing over there why don't we talk about
what you did you did a
how-to board episode about what
disneyland versus disney world give us a
little insight
look it's the exact same situation i
gave you where you have the eastern
conference western country you have the
whole thing with
california and uh you know uh california
and uh
new york against texas and florida
desantis like look we're keeping disney
world open
don't even sweat it and bob burke bob um
tiger
bob iger who was sitting on the board
for uh newsom he was helping a new
someone bringing back
you know the the state of california the
moment newsome announced that he's
still keeping a shutdown the next day
baba ago resigned he said i'm not even
doing this and bob iger is a democrat
who thought about running for office
when he wrote his book you know the book
that he wrote about the
right of a lifetime yeah so here's a ceo
he's got two
you got disneyland california disney
world florida
he's a democrat he's sitting there
saying listen as much as i'm a democrat
and why are my democrat friends keeping
my place closed and i lost 70 you know
000 jobs and over here they're keeping
it open and my guys over there have jobs
and
small business owners around there
they're staying in business but small
business owners around disneyland that
rely on that traffic
right they're going out of business
speak speaking of bob iger and bigwigs
that are kind of in newsom's camp
um i think a lot of people in silicon
valley just came out
in support of new zealand yeah well
they're all behind what is that story
why are they behind him why is big tech
behind him why is silicon valley behind
him
they're the ones saying that it's a
republican recall
right give us some energy i mean it's in
our best interest though so when it
comes down to policy
and legislation and regulations you know
he's always sided with them when it
comes to that so
i mean that's a no-brainer for the tech
industry uh i don't know if it's like
universally with the tech industry but a
big portion of the tech industry are
going to be for the champion that's for
them
and that's what's happening i just want
to talk about disneyland once more in
regards to the businesses that
have been affected the reason why
governor gavin newsom can make those
unempathetic decisions is because he has
never personally
physically built a business he's never
had a dream or ideal
that he's manifested and had that moment
when he had that first sale
or had that that opening of whatever
like some of these small businesses that
are suffering right so
it's hard to kind of lead or make this
make decisions based upon that like you
know you're kind of up here
and that's what uniquely makes me
different you know than everyone else
because i have been a part of that dream
or that aspect of having that first
creative ideal and seeing it manifest so
i know how to govern
when it comes to that and it shouldn't
be one size fit all which is where he
really failed
and i say this wholeheartedly governor
gavin newsom
could have been deemed the best governor
of california
at the beginning of all this but because
of busy guided decisions
and his uh and his uh his stances and
being seen at french laundry
he dropped the ball greatly and i think
essentially i exist because of him and
we're going to punish him for that
in regards to him no doubt you're right
about what you just said i mean
we talked about earlier that he won in a
landslide yeah
and now he's getting recalled so clearly
his decision-making ability
is questionable let's talk about what
happened with uh snow white so new scene
from disneyland snow white riot is
prompt and backlash fox business story
just days after disneyland
has reopened with an update to its snow
wide attraction the move is
already receiving backlash according to
disney snow white's enchanted
wish takes guests abroad aboard
a wooden mini card as a company the
princess as she escapes the clutches of
the evil queen
however it's the true love's kiss grand
finale between snow white and her prince
that has drawn scrutiny from san
francisco gate the new
grand finale of snow white's enchanting
which is the
most moment when the prince finds snow
white asleep
under the evil queen's spell and gives
her true love's kiss
to release her from enchantment the
outlet writes a kiss he gives to her
without her consent
while she's asleep which cannot possibly
be true love if only one person knows
it's happening haven't we already agreed
that the consent in
early disney movie is a major issue that
teaching kids that kissing
when it hasn't been established if both
parties are willing to engage
is not okay the san francisco gates said
adam i'm gonna go to you first because i
know you're like
you're with them you agree with them
this is an insult tell us what you think
about the story
well is it is this story from the onion
or is this a real this is a real story
from the
fox business regarding what san
francisco gate had to say about it all
right well
um i'm i'm with i'm with the team you
know the me too
movement people i understand you know
there's some creepy dudes out there that
you know the harvey weinsteins of the
world the cosbys of the world that have
definitely created this
but let's let's i can't believe this is
even a story let's talk about
all right you're sleeping snow white you
wake up
tell me where you'd like to be mrs white
you want to be in the castle with the
prince
or you want to be in a dwarf motel over
there down the street with seven random
midgets that you're living with i'm
taking the prince bro like
so random midgets i'm just it's not like
she's living a life of life of
luxury some prince shows up sweeps her
off her feet brings her to the castle
little people no okay you can you make
me no i'm staying i'm staying over here
with these seven little people
in some sort of hostel you want the you
want the you want the castle you want
the hostel
your picks no way the only thing is you
need to be kissed while you're sleeping
so
i'm going with the kiss how do you
process this like actually how do you
process
that's how i process it i'm going with
the prince
random midgets man i was that was that
was dropped the mic right there
you know it's literally sleepy and dopey
and grumpy and humpy
healthy yeah exactly you know you've got
these mentalities
people don't think that's a real story i
mean it's disturbing
it's this is cancer culture and it's
fine you know i think you're canceling
the prince
come on now next thing you know you're
gonna cancel prince hakeem from coming
to america this can't happen
that death of fire happened my only hope
and my prayer is that there is a tipping
point in this country where sanity
prevails
right and i'm holding out hope that we
will reach that that
threshold because i think more people
have common sense than don't
now there's going to be a market out
there for people that are offended by
this or thinks this is legit
and then let you take out your little
microscopes and look at every piece of
film
that's ever been done in the history of
mankind and by the way is there a
company more woke than disney
now you're trying to cancel a disney
character it's unbelievable
you can never satisfy these people you
will never satiate their appetite to
destroy careers
to destroy history pop culture and that
kind of thing but we don't have to let
them govern us we don't have to
take what they throw down our throat and
say this is right it's wrong it's stupid
just have some common sense and laugh at
it yeah
adam a pete got some real legit to
counsel for he says lay off the lsd
is what pete says here i thought it was
a very uh you know we appreciate that
pete but the last person
i totally understand if you want to skip
this story there's no upside for the
answer
but that's what you tell them after the
story we just talked about what this
leads me
to the jay-z story okay here's what
jay-z says on page 11 if you want to go
to the last page we got there
jay-z all the way at the bottom jay-z
says cancel culture is here to stay and
feel sorry for the younger generation
it's unbelievable metro uk story jay-z
has shared his thoughts on the internet
cancer culture and predicts it'll be
around as long as social media exists
cancer culture has been discussed
increasingly in recent years and
involves large groups or fandoms
deciding
to essentially erase a celebrity or
public figures career in public
uh prominence in light of a scandal or
controversial issue the paper explained
how he feels sorry for the younger
generation growing up in a social media
era explaining
you can't give someone a microphone for
24 hours a day and have them not think
that they have to use
use it the these kids it's unbelievable
imagine having a microphone and you're
asked about social justice questions
at 18 years old it's like what i'm meant
to answer
i'm meant to know the answer and if you
don't
if i don't answer the correct way if i
don't say any
everything right even if i mention my
intentions my intentions are right
and i don't say the same right thing
it's going to be
everywhere i mean he's got a great point
there yeah i was impressed i was really
impressed but do you agree that it's
here too
okay and let me say that's the part you
know what he could have taken two routes
there he could say
it's here to stay or this is temporary
and it's going away i applaud him
i thank you jay-z for saying it's here
to stay and i'll tell you why because i
think
he identifies it as a fringe element
okay
like he minimizes a little bit by just
saying okay it's not going to go away
there's always going to be young people
social media
isn't leaving so don't take it too
seriously if he said this thing's going
to go away
it's not and then you legitimize it i
think now you can just look at these
people that are doing this
fringe element they're wackos they're
always going to be around you know move
on
nothing to see here no i agree and and
that's happening even with with me with
the campaign and i think that's happened
to so many
you know celebrities and people in the
past you do have to just look over it
you have to understand that it is it
isn't going anywhere but you
i think that does minimize it and take
away a little bit of the the flame that
they were having and this as you said
like
why give in to them why make them matter
even more so
and with me is it's hard because i want
to like protect myself and just
say certain things and it's like a
double-edged sword because they
screenshot and use it for more content
so i call them content predators as well
well i think we've established that
anyone can be a media company these days
any
16 year old with the phone hey welcome
to the joe blow show and here's my
thoughts
i think we can all agree that citizen
journalism is what they're calling it
ppd
at 18 major at 18. tom and 18.
adam at 18 is a lot different than adam
at 38 42 45
big your your thoughts and your
everything evolves
and at this point with cancel culture
they're going back
well he said this in 1994
so we got a cancer right look at his
twitter account yeah look at his
so like i think
it that everything is so out there these
days that
you just need to be careful what you
said and i think that's essentially what
jay-z is saying
i don't i actually i'm on the opposite
side i don't want to be careful yeah
i i don't i don't i don't know about
that because let me tell you you're
arrested when you're like that you're
walking on eggshells when you're like
that look i get it like listen
there is like we talked about the other
day there is 98
of things we'll talk about openly then
we've got the two percent that we're
probably not going to talk about on
camera
i get it we'll talk two percent you know
it's going to be a different
conversation everybody has that small
percentage somebody's one percent some
is two percent some is ten percent
closer to one but
you're closer to maybe two three i think
that's a fair assessment i'm not running
for governor
i'm not running for donald trump but now
you're you're living in a time that
people are being told to be closer to 50
percent
so meaning just be fake on the camera
just be fake don't tell what you think
just be
but they but they want real yeah
relatability they want to
just be fake yes raw fakeness yeah
again i i think i think people still
want the realness i think what people
want is for you to be able to stand
against the heat and say okay listen
somebody said this about about you let's
see what you're going to say about it
okay cool we'll respect you you want to
took the argument
you lost seven of the 28 arguments you
want 21 of them
fair cool we're good to go let's move on
to the next and then they get over right
cancer culture is also predicated based
on how the individual handles the cancer
culture
when they're being cancelled it also has
to do with that because jay-z
is probably right it probably isn't
going away in a very very long time
of people being cancelled but let me let
me show you guys a video i want to show
you a video neither one of you guys have
seen it i always send it to you i only
send it to kai
so we had uh uh uh who what was the show
that was cancelled a year ago
uh uh what was the show called live pd
say you hit your mic oh yeah live
live pd got cancelled right remember
live peter when he got cancelled
deputy mark or something like that right
when he got canceled
sheriff mark lam so when he got canceled
we brought him up
and i said what do you think about
defund police and he said defund police
is a bunch of crap what are you gonna do
when he called the cops and all this
other stuff and he's like
so people who are you know were
supportive of defund police send me
emails saying what are you talking about
you know you know
all you think about is all cops are
right and all this others i said no i
actually have had bad experiences with
cops and i've had good experience with
cops
but more of my experiences have been
good that have been bad i said okay
nozzario a couple weeks ago
we showed the video about nizari who's
sitting there saying man i got my hands
out i got my hand that's the
the second lieutenant who's got my hands
over my hands and then we brought the
uh his lawyer on and we interviewed the
lawyer and folks who are for
protecting the police they said why
would you bring somebody like that on
why would you do something like that
the cops were right he was wrong all
this i said listen i see the story and i
want to cover the story
whether i agree or not i want to see the
story to learn from it
right this is all leading to
people acting in a certain way because
the media is telling them all cops are
bad i want you to watch this video what
happens yesterday
kai if you can get the video ready just
just i want to get your reaction on this
it's gotten 3.3 million views in 15
hours
so watch what happens here it's two
minutes go ahead
yes you are ma'am good morning which is
and the speed limit is 40 and i was
going 38. can you raise the volume a
little bit
well correct with your phone yes i
started to record because
you can't be on your cell phone while
it's at my apartment what's your
apartment
it's at my home i'm just taking my
do you have your driver's license if i
mistakenly left it at home do you have a
picture of your driver's license
yes i do have it and can you call your
supervisor please
i already did he's on his way because
you're
[Music]
is
okay can you zoom in on that for me yeah
thank you
see how what she says at the end is she
a white lady
listen you're a murderer okay what's
your last name i can't see that there
stop shaking white lady zoom in on that
phone no because you're scaring me
they're threatening to kill me and my
son can you give me okay
listen listen listen karen
you're trying to threaten to kill me i'm
not smiling you're the one
hold that still i can't see that is this
your car yes it is
and you're trying to say i stole my own
car because you're jealous
yeah what the why wait for me right here
okay you're jealous
all you need is your signature he's only
citing you for using your cell phone
while you're driving that's
it for him being a mexican racist
what does that mean sign the citation
man here you go mexican racist
you're always going to be a mexican
you'll never be white you know that oh
my god
you'll never be right which is what you
really want to be
right you want to be white
in front of her unbelievable wow
how are you processing this what made
you show us this video let me let me put
it to you
who the hell wants to be a cop today
yeah who the hell wants to be a cop like
t
you tell me wake up in the morning you
see the i can't wait to be a cop who
wants to be a cop today
he handled that so well every job every
job comes with a certain
pride that you want to do it right okay
why you want to be a firefighter i got
pride
why you want to be a governor because i
want to make an impact why you want to
be
you know a media because i want to go
out there and entertain people why you
want to go out there and do what you do
write a book i want impact why do you
want to be a cop i want to protect them
so writing
who the hell wants to be a cop today
what what kid is saying i want to grow
up
it's going to be a very very major
problem and i've seen that screenshot
but i haven't watched the video yet so
that's unbelievable
is that even legal can you talk to a
police officer like that i don't think
she should be arrested and cancelled
both that's humble
whether she was a cop it was a cop that
ran up on her she's
forget my language she's just a piece of
[ __ ] she's a she's the definition of a
karen and
you're trying to murder me like relax
ladies and gentlemen
the whole mexican white thing i mean
[ __ ] let me ask you a question
so who is to blame for that obviously
the
sole responsibility goes on the
individual yeah that's the 80 is her
i i'm with that 80 responsibility goes
on there yes
but who else is responsible for that i
mean he put that in their back
right the media 24 7
cops to be bad then you have something
like this imagine that guy's going home
telling his wife you know
it's freaking bad experience today man
let me tell you what happened i don't
sick of doing my job like imagine that
conversation at night right babe i'm
sick of being a cop i want to change my
career
what's the wife going to say do it babe
this on a daily basis but i mean that
was the epitome of racism i mean
everything she was doing it was intense
and they
they paint themselves as the people that
are
you know fighting the other battle it's
unbelievable wow that was intense and
you wonder is that
is that normal i mean do you think
police are abused like that on a regular
basis
they must be here about what do you hear
from police since you're obviously pro
police you're not trying to defund the
police well i mean a lot of them
is you know the morale is low you know
and they are
on the brink of is this what i want to
continue to do
a lot of them because and anything that
you're doing especially in public
service you want to
you don't do it for the credit but you
do want to be appreciated well you are
working like a service yeah every day
they put their life into absolutely
yeah and so you know they they do feel
it they're you know
and they're on the edge of if they want
to walk away from this you know because
you know they're up against multiple
things psychologically with the media
the social media and the polarizing uh
commentary that's you know that's a part
of their job and their responsibility so
um you know it that was a harsh video to
watch man
for anyone whether you're pro police not
pro police yeah
let's not be pro police i mean other
than the i'm talking about solely
the function and then i think about the
component of her her kid being with her
you know i'm really
you know that that really disturbed me
you know as well because psychologically
you know
what the kid is processing it also so
it's a perpetual cycle and that's a
snapshot of her day i mean you know that
continues throughout the day and her on
social media going on what a danger
so now so so now the kid is 14 to 17
years old and have a
encounter and is belligerent you know
towards an officer and then something
happens right but it all
it's the seeds of the planet in regards
to how they react who's who's the kid's
hero the kid's heroes is mom
right so what's up my mom is like those
two cops i got to be like that to cops
because the kid wants to be loyal to the
parents so kid's going to duplicate
whatever the parent believes and that's
typically what happens
maybe i mean but there's you could also
be embarrassed by your mom like
when my dad ever did that i'd be like
what are you doing
subconsciously a lot of it you know
that's going to stick they say there's
more caught than taught in parenting
you can teach all you want to do the
right things your kid's going to do what
you do not teach what you do
this is catching the kid just caught
what the parent just did
that's pathetic to me to do that and by
the way again
who's the responsibility who is
responsible for that
who is responsible for that who do you
think the dividers those who get paid to
divide there's a business model to
division
the division business model has been
around for a very very long time the
media business
the media business model is either to
make you think
to entertain or to divide or to be
controversial
change conflict that's their business
model it is you either are a very
entertainer where i'm sitting there
saying oh my gosh i just needed to laugh
you know
you know how it's friday night you're
sitting there you're kids are gone
it's eleven o'clock at night you're like
two okay you go to movies you say drama
comedy horror i'm like yeah i need some
comedy right now seriously
30 minutes and then you go to like a
wedding crash and you go to your
favorite part right and you watch it for
10 15 minutes
get it out of your system there's
different methods to comedy today to
entertainment today
this is a business model divide divide
divide
and buy and sell and there's a huge
market for it unfortunately it is it
really is
a big market for okay so let's talk
about buffett let's see what buffett has
to say about the whole thing that's
going on by the way
i got a question for the viewers i've
never seen this happen
suddenly the viewership drops by three
to four hundred
if you're watching this comment below if
you by any chance were kicked out we've
done 58 episodes i've never seen this
before
were you accidentally kicked out and you
had to come back on
and you don't know why if you were just
kind of let us on the comment section
i'm doing more of a focus group for
myself because i keep asking salmon
ganker to see what's going on it's going
from 2700 to 12
drops to 2 300. i've never seen that
happen before sometimes that happens
because service is bad
sometimes it happened when our internet
is bad but we have no issue over here
with the internet so if you guys don't
mind
commenting uh this is just for me to
know what's going on here okay
facebook says decision on whether trump
ban will be overturned coming wednesday
page number four let's see what's going
on
no no let's go to uh to him first and
then we'll go to warren buffett
facebook says decision on whether trumpy
uh banned will be overturned coming
wednesday cnn business story
their oversight board will announce its
long-anticipated decision on the fate of
former president trump facebook account
at 9am eastern standard time on
wednesday announced monday morning
the board said last month that it had
received 9 000 plus public responses
concerning trump's indefinite
suspension from facebook and instagram
facebook suspended trump's account
following the january 6 capital rights
and later referred the decision to the
court-like oversight board
an independent body which has the power
to reverse facebook content decisions
and said president uh
for the company later that month
facebook asked the oversight board for
ruling on whether to let trump's
suspension stand
saying the significance of the matter
warranted its independent review
thoughts well i is there anybody
that thinks it's going to get overturned
i i don't think there's a chance in hell
that he's back on i think there is but
okay oh and i i just don't think there
is
this is the facebook supreme court um
it's happened six times where they've
done it what i think they overruled it
twice couldn't decide one time but
no i don't think so and and here's what
they're gonna lean on they're gonna lean
on the one thing that got him banned it
was
it was the video where he says we love
you we think you're very special i mean
look you might not agree with the rules
but the rules are in place
and there's consequences to having a
message like that
on that day and my prediction is i don't
think he's going to be back on facebook
okay what do you think i'm kind of 50 50
with it but i also may look at
look at look at it like they're looking
at him as competition you know because
there is rumors going around that he's
going to launch
a social media platform or partner with
someone as well too so if this is going
to be your social media you don't want
to give
him your platform that opportunity to
promote and uh bring followers over from
that particular platform as well so i'm
kind of 55th in regards to if they will
or won't do it
i know that they're getting a lot of
pushback on it as well but you know
council culture they don't care don't
you think it's a little bit more
difficult to just say you're going to
start your own social media platform
yeah yeah absolutely absolutely once
more when you're
when you're at his level it's not about
him doing it these things are already in
the works you partner with individuals
who have already done the work and then
you put the money behind in your
influence and
tied out that you have it so do you
think they will or they won't would you
he said he's 50 50. yeah i'm 50 50 only
if they will if they won't um
i think more than the trump situation
here
is this the power of big tech like the
fact that
the facebook gods the overlords are like
well should we or should we and not
allow the former president of the united
states to be on our platform
i think it's such a huge decision that
it's
it's ridiculous and i'm in case you
haven't gotten the memo not a trump fan
in the least right but i think that you
should at least
allow the former president united states
to have
a place on your platform now if you want
to put
like literally behind every message that
he does
this message has been fact checked and
he's definitely a liar and
you know he over exaggerates and he's
definitely divisive you want to do all
that
but to ban him from being on a platform
is ridiculous and don't forget i think
trump's
approval ratings were hovering in the
low 40s facebooks and mark zucker
mark zuckerbergs are hovering in the 20s
and 30s yeah but so
to be worse than trump you know it's
pretty bad i just think
their history they're not do how much
heat would they take from all the other
social media companies
if they allowed him back it would put
this this pressure then on twitter to
allow him back i
i strongly believe there's no chance one
thing i know for sure
we'll be covering this story on thursday
right yeah i think that i think there's
a chance
i think there's a chance because i think
this is if you remember uh zuck took a
couple positions uh where
he said look we're a a content we're a
social media website so we don't dictate
what policies we put in what policies we
don't and he made some decision that
pissed off the left
i don't know if you remember this was
like two years ago a year and a half ago
they were not happy about the position
he took
and he gets backlash from both sides all
the time you got to give credit to zuck
on the one end where
both sides hate them there's almost a
little bit of credibility when both
sides hate you
at times rather than just one-sided
ratings are yeah so
20 but but the point is the reason why
both sides hate him is because sometimes
he
takes a stand that is not republican and
sometimes he takes a stand that's not
democratic so
i think there is a chance they may allow
him back with certain restrictions where
your
every post has to be approved type of
situation where they may come out and
say the post has to be
recreated a committee that all they do
is watch trump's post
and they say here's what is posted do we
want to approve this put it up
and maybe something like that but i do
think there's a 10 20 percent challenge
i was going to ask you you're an odds
guy you're going with 10. i think
there's a 20
[Applause]
six times it's been overturned upheld
them twice
one time could uh they couldn't have
come up with a decision
so they have actually overturned it six
times the majority huh
look trump's news is getting out he's
sending email to the media nowadays he
responds and puts email says oscar needs
to go back to this you know this needs
to go back to this
so his message is being picked up he's
just sending emails as much as
horse is not at that of course it's not
let me but if i have to choose
if i have to choose you got twitter you
got youtube you got facebook
meaning google right so youtube so you
got facebook google
twitter who's most likely to let him
back on not twitter
okay so that's last that's the last yeah
he ain't coming back so who's most
likely
to facebook youtube yeah i think it's
probably gonna be facebook youtube then
twitter
here's another thing to consider do you
think there's a possibility he's
enjoying his life
with a little less stress no you don't
think so i think he's such a sore loser
that there's
he's zero percent happy about what's
going on right now i i believe he's
festering and he he's ready to come back
and just do it just to annoy a lot of
people
at the end of the day he's also 72 maybe
he's tired 70
he's not sure trump don't get tired he's
74 74 he's got the body like an 84 year
old in the mind of a four-year-old he's
gonna be back baby
i don't know man it's a comfortable
lifestyle up there why do you what is it
about
trump that you enjoy well you so
that's a great question um i i've never
known not to like trump you know i come
from an environment from an
urban environment where we've always
admired trump you know from just from uh
from a celebrity standpoint from the
gold buildings
from the rap videos from the from the
movie appearances
it wasn't it was never political it was
popular it was only to politically
very people told me you turned since
they told me not to like them just
because and then there are certain
things that i understand about human
beings i understand that i don't have to
agree with everything 100
i like i like strength i like
individuals that say what they
say and they're unorthodox and
untraditional which is why i talk about
the electrician that's
you know that's unapologetically
different right and i think he
represented that for the time and moment
in regards to what our country needed
and it was simplistically just based
upon that so were there things that
you're like look i appreciate them i
respect them but
uh yeah that i can't do what were those
some tweets and some sometimes just
having that uh
uh that certain stance on on answering
questions straightforward in regards to
white
supremacy and things of that nature like
you could just go ahead and do it
even though you've answered it and that
was the biggest thing you have to say
you got to answer the same questions
over and over i know that it can be
get redundant i get it all the time
actually man i just answered that like
literally two seconds ago just
what about like the confederate flags he
was kind of yeah you know not
siding with taking it down obviously you
probably have strong opinions on that
right well honestly i wasn't really
educated in regards to what that truly
meant
at that particular time in regards to
why people felt forward or even felt
against it but also just the foundation
of choice
like if that's what you're for that's
what you're for i don't have to agree
with it and so i never took a hard
stance when it came to that because
it doesn't it doesn't bother me it like
my life continues to be with my life
does that not bother you adam likes to
be emotional
it's part of his well no one is no one
is bringing it up to me
like it's not in uh there's not anyone
in my yard
you know making me acknowledge it or
anything of that nature so i just don't
own
every every issue in every every um
activism type of thing people want me to
be a part i told you about i'm working
on my emotions i get it
i'm getting much better i'm trying to
hold it in
so okay we'll see wednesday tomorrow we
get the news yes uh folks if you're
watching
what do you think likelihood let's let's
let's do a survey here i'd love to hear
the
likelihood if you say there's no way in
the world they're gonna approve him
smash the thumbs up button
if you say they're gonna approve him
he's gonna be uh back on facebook
put the thumbs down let's see what's
gonna happen here i'm actually curious
to know what's gonna happen with this
we got 75228 how do you see the let's
see
i'll tell you here in a minute when i
see the ratios okay let's go to buffett
buffett buffett buffett buffett page
five
oh man they said a lot of different
things here okay so
stuff lots of stuff yes so buff it
uh let's go to the story warren buffett
says bad leaders pose biggest
risk to companies a wall street journal
story poor management is a top three
facing companies according to warren
buffett the chief executive conglomerate
berkshire hathaway said choosing the
wrong people to lead an organization
is the number one risk for businesses in
his five decades running berkshire
buffett said
he has seen a number of companies fail
from textile mills to department stores
and he suggested that a consistent
element could be found
in those failures beyond changing
consumer behavior or shifting market
forces
you get a guy or a woman in charge of it
they're
they're personable the directors like
him they don't
know what they're doing but they know
how to put on an appearance
that's the biggest single danger buffett
said very interesting
very interesting what do you think about
that major well for me it's um
it's a little dated i feel like it is
dated i feel that there are individuals
that are way more talented and skilled
even from the appearance
perspective because as i said earlier
early even from a political standpoint
it does matter that you have experience
in in politics but it does
doesn't matter if you're not willing to
be open
to the evolution of how to lead you know
people or galvanize or even win a
particular election so when it comes to
what he's specified
that's more of a niche perspective which
drastic has drastically changed in a lot
of different industries and
um you know i get it i respect his mind
i respect the temperament of what he's
saying
but i think it's stemming from a little
resentment you know these
social media app companies have uh
they're they're being very uh what's
what's the word for it um
uh um they're uh disruptors they're this
you know and his his model is very
different and so when it's something
that you don't understand
and they didn't ask him for permission
that's what happens no different than
what i'm doing i'm not asking for
permission
i've chosen to exist i'm experienced
because of my mindset and what i'm
telling you that i
you know i'm experienced and we're going
to do this together so i think there is
a little resentment there
there is a little bias that's a part of
that i still respect his mind he's done
a lot of great things
but evolution does occur and it does
exist yes it does that is the truth adam
what do you think
about this specific leadership question
or just the leadership question
we talked about this like who's hosting
the oscars like the who's the face of
the brand yeah
um the person at top does matter like
the ceo does need to drive a company i
mean you would have the best perspective
on this i think
more than anyone right you being as a
ceo leading the field
leading the sales force leading your
entire company
i think that that's essentially his his
point here i mean what i
i'm more to be honest with you more
intrigued by the
the 10 key takeaways which is probably
the next story we're going with
you know what why don't we go to the
story of uh california taxes why don't
we talk about that before we go into the
takeaways because i think that's uh
can i give you one question sure buffalo
you know it's ironic i think that he's
talking about executive leadership ceo
leadership because
i think there's he's punched some holes
in his own leadership right now i think
he skews old now
i think he hurt his brand excuse all
right well i mean no but i mean come on
seriously charlie's 100 he's 90 yeah but
you know what you and i
of course but i mean never in the past
has he come across this grumpy old guy
for sure
and the other thing that kind of creeped
into his messaging is arrogance to me
i take arrogance out of that and for
someone as brilliant as the oracle of
omaha warren buffett he missed a great
opportunity he should have been speaking
to these kids
that invest on robin hood and try to
bring them into his fold and say hey
you know good job maybe you could come
over and do some things in berkshire
hathaway we got a platform for you too
it's not
it seems like he's a supper club owner
right he needs to have a little happy
hour
thrown onto that menu right just lighten
up and loosen up those are some of the
takeaways that i i want to touch i know
how to move but you know what they
remind me of him in charlie monger you
see the muppets and the two old guys
up in the uh in the audience like oh you
idiot muppets down there
yeah but but let me let me read this
story and then we'll get into the pages
of that
same page page five when asked about
people leaving california because of
taxes and high cost of living
mr munger said he thought state
governments were making a mistake and
allowing residents to be
wooed elsewhere i do think it is stupid
for states to drive
out their wealthiest citizens mr munger
said the old people don't commit any
crimes they donate to a local charity
who in the hell in the right mind would
drive out the rich people florida and
places like that
are very shrewd and places like
california are being very
stupid that's monger do you agree i
agree
okay tell us why i agree i mean when you
look at the top
you know five percent one percent they
add so much value that a lot of people
don't take credit for or give them
credit for
uh they are the ones who uh you know
donate to foundations they are the ones
who give back they are the ones who
you know employ you know thousands if
not millions of individuals and provide
those opportunities
um i i don't this i don't agree with the
culture that we're in now to eat the
rich culture
uh you know i don't believe that looking
at someone like you you know that's
successful and being
becoming envious of that i look at you
and i get inspired and then i start to
try to dig and see how you did it or if
i get a chance to meet you like i have
now
asked you you know what did you do or
what are your what is your insight so a
lot of people don't think that way so
i would encourage people to change that
mindset when it comes to that and why
punish them
you know this is a successful model here
in florida right you know they
they are very shrewd when it comes to
how they receive that and they want to
retain those individuals
and you should want to rule people to to
stay because that's tax revenue that's
going to help infrastructure
it's going to help the you know the
economy grow you know you know what
these guys will remind me of by the way
great point he's making with monk
why would you want to lose your
wealthiest people yeah what do they do
like do they even have the energy to go
commit a crime they got money
they're going to spend money they're
going to buy stuff they're going to
reinvest in the community they're going
to hey we need a million dollars to
build a church bringing a million
dollars for the school
here you go here's a half a million
here's 100 why would you want to lose
these guys
there is no logic in wanting to lose
your wealthiest people who are typically
your oldest people that you have in your
community because it takes a while to
compound interest
right create that why would you want to
lose him yeah i was a little
underwhelmed by his comment to be honest
with you because i just thought it was
so obvious
i mean i i would rather hear from him
maybe some solutions or some other ideas
but
it's because these governors are so
short-sighted all they think about is
tax revenue right and you know they're
going to create and
they don't they're not they have no
vision so all they can just go back to
their imagination
all they can think about is what can i
do to have someone like me the next day
i'll just give them more money or we'll
come up with a new camp
or a government aid program or something
so there's that just the lack of
inspiration from these guys is just
demoralizing so let me just go through
the 10 key takeaways and let's process
it together so these are the tanki
takeaways
from buffett and charlie munger at the
berkshire hathaway's 2021 shareholder
meeting this is a story by nasdaq i'll
just say the main
uh a point of what it is and then we'll
go process it together number one stock
market leadership is fleeting
number two buffett and monger disagree
on s p 500 versus
berkshire hathaway meaning buffett said
i've never recommended berkshire 20
anybody as he has always wanted to avoid
any appearances i've given any inside
tip on the stock
of the company he runs but monger has a
different view he says i personally
prefer holding berkshire to holding the
market he said
arguing that berkshire's set of
businesses and investment aren't
are in his view better than the average
across the market even though berkshire
hathaway has not beat the s p 500 the
last decade by the way
number three buff it airlines have done
better because we sold
i love it number four a minor mistake
from buffett some have questioned why
buffett
uh trimmed a steak in uh tech giant
apple the oracle of omaha minute that
was probably a mistake charlie in his
usual low-key way
let me know it was a mistake number five
why buffett doesn't like spax
buffett express is dislike for the spac
business model specifically the
requirement for most packs
have to find a business within two years
if you put a gun to my head and said
you've got to go buy a business within
two years
i'd buy one buffett said but it wouldn't
be much of one number six
views on the impact of low interest
rates number seven
monger on bitcoin responding to a
shareholder question about bitcoin
buffett decided to dodge the question
his motivation avoiding making the
hundreds of thousands of viewers who
owned the cryptocurrency unhappy but
monger didn't hold back he said
i hate bitcoin success okay the whole
damn development is disgusting and
contrary to the interest of civilization
number eight a buffett dig at elon musk
when asked another shareholder question
was addressed to berkshire head of
insurance business
uh asking whether he'd write an
insurance policy for tesla ceo and
spacex
founder elon musk for his proposed
missions to mars
jane quickly said no buffett d murrd
however it would depend on the premium
the berkshire hathaway ceo said
and i would probably have a somewhat
different rate if elon was
on board number nine buffett and monger
smackdown robin hood this one got ugly
by the way they didn't have nice things
to say about him they said
become a you know uh buffett and monger
however were deeply critical of brooke
buffett noted that robin hood has become
a very significant part of the casino
group that's joined the stock market in
the last year and a half
monger went further it's just god awful
that some something like that would draw
investment from civilized men and
citizens
uh decent citizens it's deeply wrong and
last but not least berkshire's dynamic
duo has learned
some lessons in the last year so adam
i've said a lot
what are your thoughts so you went down
the list i think i thought it was a
a very good breakdown shout out to kai
for doing the research and yeah this was
great
you know i feel like i've taken a whole
uh
economics class just from kai's research
so thank you
last night exactly so shout out to major
and i doing our research but
a couple of things that that stuck out
for me from that list is number one
this gentleman named greg abel is going
to be stepping in
for uh warren buffett and charlie munger
and i thought it was a i had to write a
little lol note here and he said that
between the two people
that i was choosing from between greg
abel and
ajit what's the gentleman's name ajit
ajit jain
he went with greg because he was young
abel was 59 versus 69 i think that's
rich coming from a 90 year old
and a 98 year old we're going to go with
the young guy here
then um their hate on bitcoin
just feels out of touch and they
probably do have some valid points don't
get me wrong if you've made a
60-year career of investing in companies
with
you know p e ratios and earnings and
leaders and and everything that a real
company
possesses and now you just have these
you know
uh digital wallet assets decentralized
cryptocurrency
i i feel like they have this opportunity
to go you know you talked about legacy
legacy what do i want my kids to be
known as
what do you want these young investors
to remember you as these sour
old dudes that hated on you or the
greatest investor of all time that kind
of gave you some wisdom
in their final days and the the i mean
business-wise it is finals easy stepping
down
but last but not least i think this is
something interesting um
regarding the smackdown on robin hood
for someone who's
such an advocate for investing and get
out there and compound interest and buy
the s
p robin hood with their flaws and
gamifying investing i can understand why
you would maybe have some issue
issues with it but they're allowing
retail investors to get into the market
and that's something that i'm all about
is
save that money so you can start
investing and if you're getting stimulus
checks if you're sitting at home and
you're saving money because you've never
been able to
travel or spend it at the club and
you're 20 30 something years old
and you're able to start investing it
yeah you might
lose a little bit but you're going to
definitely win because you're going to
learn a lesson
especially if you buy a company like a
gamestop or an amc
or the meme stocks or whatever you're
going to learn something
so i think he seems a little out of
touch kai you're trying to say something
go ahead
yeah no i mean i think it's interesting
how um
i'd say almost sounds like you guys are
surprised in a sense the way they're
saying it is
but if you look at it that's the way
they've invested all their careers
they're value investors they're looking
for things they can understand
how much was warren buffett criticized
in the dakota boom
when he didn't invest but he said i
don't understand it i don't feel safe to
invest it so i'm not going to try to
gamble he's always the safe bet right
and especially with
uh with charlie munger coming in then it
was like all right we're going to do
we're going to invest in something that
is works
that's proven and that can run itself he
said if uh
with coca-cola if the ceo was a ham
sandwich it would still make money
right that's their whole philosophy
that's their whole way bitcoin
and cryptocurrency as far as we know
it's still all just speculation it's
just
we can't there's no there's no um forms
or
or kind of earnings that say oh this is
going to project it to earn here and
here
in many ways you can put up you can put
calculations and say
but you can also put calculations to say
otherwise so the fact that they're
against this isn't surprising in my ways
obviously they're getting older and you
can kind of argue that as well
but they've always been the hair versus
the tortoise and they've always been
slow and steady wins the race and
like with robin hood you're not betting
necessarily on the market you're picking
a stock
and it's you're getting confetti for
buying you're getting confetti for
selling
so in many ways it's going against
everything that they're against
which is or which they're not for uh
because they've always been the slow and
steady wins the race
good good stuff kai you know i think you
guys have handled it you know most of
the key issues here
i'm convinced that they invested in a
tequila company or they're both a little
buzzed when they were talking
because that was just so against the
grain for them being this outspoken
talking this much trash you know i
ultimately i don't know it was a great
look for them because a
i admit i screwed up on apple i mean
that's kind of a big error that's what
sticks with me you got 10 points
i screwed up on apple i don't like
bitcoin i got something with elon musk
and and robin hood sucks i mean that's
really what i got from this let me let
me ask you
how competitive do you think monger and
buffett are competitive
how competitive you think they are you
know i think warren is extremely i think
i don't know anything about
i think he's got that killer mindset
right okay so here's here's how i see
this
uh when is it good to retire in baseball
or in basketball what's
good after a good season when is it a
good time
you've lost a step or two when you
barkley said when scrubs are beating me
that's for that's time for me to retire
right barkley said when scrubs are
beating me and i'm sitting there saying
this scrub just beat me who the hell is
he
it's time for me to get out the league
right okay i
i don't know obviously investments is a
different
uh world because you can invest a lot
longer like meaning your tenure to want
to invest maybe your tenure to play
basketball is what say 10 or 20 years
okay you're kobe 20 years
yeah i know but i'm just saying let's
say 10 or 20 years carmel is still
playing he became the 10th all-time
scorer
say he's 10 or 20 years what's your 10
year for investments
what is it 50 years 40 years there's got
to still be a tenure
what is the number so do i think maybe
10 years ago they should have retired
maybe 10 years ago they should have
replaced themselves maybe 15 years ago
they should replace themselves i don't
know one of the hardest things to do is
when you
look at someone you know do you remember
that interview
who's the guy the boxing commentator who
he's famous for always interviewing
boxers after the fight he's looking at
mayweather and he says
but why did you hit him in the face when
he wasn't looking is that larry merchant
larry merchant right now very much if if
i was
if i was 20 years younger i beat you or
whatever right
and then you wouldn't know that i like
to see you try it
going back and forth right but you have
to realize larry
is sitting there saying dude i'm 75 but
if i was 25
i would have whooped your ass let's just
say that's the mindset because he goes
back and remembers who's 25.
think about buffett sitting there saying
who the hell are you guys i've been
going at this for freaking nine
eight years since i was 10 years old
investing again who are you schmucks
when i went into those meetings to want
to learn about being an investment
banker
but there's there's a flaw in that
there's a weakness in it it's almost
like this
okay i had a girlfriend of mine years
ago
and she was modeling acting movies all
that other stuff i said you know you
know
there's one thing you got to be very
careful with she says what i said if the
only way you get attention is your looks
when it goes away you're psychologically
going to have a meltdown
when it goes away because it's
eventually going to go away for
everybody
yeah you're going to look like this
forever just so you know that there's
gravity things work against you as you
age it's just not going to be in your
favor long term
buffet and monger are the examples to me
of a drop that gorgeous girl
that they no longer look good because
better looking girls are coming up and
they have a hard time because they no
longer get the attention that they used
to get
i may be fully wrong i may be absolutely
off base here and i'm missing it but
i think for them the route that you were
recommending fantastic route to say hey
why don't we bring these younger guys
together see what we can do why don't
you think you can do something come on
down let's create a summit and bring
them up why do you think about this
and closed doors not even open hey bring
the bitcoin guy anthony papliano we just
had there that he went they're going
back
yeah bring some of these guys in that
they don't know nothing about what is
the future because the reality of it is
you kind of got a pivot you know you
kind of got a pivot right now ebay just
announced they're about to take a
bitcoin matter of fact one
this was our first week ever where one
of the companies i'm hiring as a
consultant they paid as a by bitcoin wow
like do you receive i'm like yeah sure
we'll receive by bitcoin i would send
a bunch of ethereum no problem people
are now going in that direction
and whether you like it or not you have
to pivot i don't know if they're doing
that
it's 10 56. i don't know if we have time
for one more story i got 11 o'clock call
but if you guys got final thoughts
major williams i'm gonna give you the
final thoughts you know what you want to
say with california
sell us the dream on why you believe
california is going to come back and
it's going to be
uh the state that it used to be where
everybody around the world would go to
rather than states like texas and
florida tell us the dream well the
opportunity
is there first of all we have to
acknowledge that we are unified in
frustration
and it is one of those things kind of
like the statement that you said you
know
try me you know and that's something
that i'm really going to hang my head on
in regards to
if you are on the fence but you should
understand that california has
great comeback ability because of what
we represent
and it is going to take a different
brand of leadership that understands the
issues and knows how to actually get
those issues solved
and be realistic about how we can do
those things collectively together
i do believe that as the next governor
of california we can
get things done beyond just the
government perspective
being the next governor of california
you know that's going to be global news
not just statewide news and that in
itself
allows me to open up other doors and get
people excited about the change of
culture of leadership
and so that's something i think that
other people are really excited about as
well the exclusivity
and being a part of what we can do
together so this is not my campaign
in california i tell everyone this is
our campaign and i think that's the
that's the pretense of it you got a
great message you got a lot of momentum
best of luck if there's any way i can
help you in california
i know a lot of people would love to
hear what you're talking about and
that's just what you got to do just got
to stay out there yeah have people here
because it's going to be impossible not
to like you hey can i just address the
elephant in the room real quickly
next time that you guys get together on
the wardrobe and you look like very
well-dressed cia agents or
secret service i've stepped off the
cover of gq
i won't raid the wardrobe closet of get
shorty okay and i'll just kind of you
look like you flew here from louisville
you look like you're full here from
louisville
that's what you're looking that's
exactly that's a good look for you what
are you
trying to do you have a pink
photographer i guarantee you everybody's
looking at you more than
us right for sure and you also said you
know what i'm already feeling a little
derby
let me throw a little pink in there
there we go so you made that decision
baby
well my my final piece is shout out to
major williams
respect man thank you for coming through
i think thanks for having me um
you know you you answered the tough
questions you answered the
easy questions but clearly you handle
yourself well and last shout out i think
definitely goes to
the godfather of soul james brown for uh
try me
try me and um papa's got a brand new bag
and it's major williams
i put his link again at the bottom in
the chat box go give the man a follow
and dm him and let him know what you
took away from today's podcast if you
enjoyed it subscribe as well
with that being said we are doing it
again this thursday i think this
thursday yes sir
is daniel de martino booth i believe
danielle is coming to down this
town this thursday so we'll see you then
thank you everybody bye bye bye bye
you